Good Morning, and welcome back to another episode
of The Joy of Mathematics. I'm Toby and today
we're going to be talking about the world of white
holes. You might have heard of black holes before,
these scary sinks of gravitational potential
from which nothing can escape. Black holes
were predicted to exist a long time ago and
then scientists eventually found evidence
that they do exist. Well, white holes are
kind of like the opposite of black holes,
they are born in the depths of a black hole
where time dances backwards. Nothing can enter
a white hole but everything inside of it will
eventually be pushed out. For now white holes
remain just a mathematical prediction and we
haven't detected any but thinking about white
holes helps us to understand the physics in a
deeper way. This video was inspired by Carlo
Rovelli's latest book White Holes and thank
you to Riverhead Books for sending me a copy.
The book doesn't try to convince you that
white holes exist because they might not,
instead it talks about what it is like to play in
the mathematical sandpit of these abstract ideas,
abstract as a white hole and what it means
to think about them and to research them.
Rovelli's book will be available wherever
books are sold in the US from the 31st
of October and that book will help you to
understand these concepts in a deeper way.
Black holes are as abundant as the stars that
twinkle in the night sky. In fact many black
holes are formed from dying Stars. When stars
are alive they are radiant burning hydrogen.
"Every day is a good day when you're a star"
you could imagine them singing for billions of
harmonious years. But eventually they will have
a bad day. Their fuel is steadily running out
turning into helium and other elements. When
the most enormous stars run out of fuel they
collapse under the irresistible pool of gravity
becoming black holes. Matter isn't swallowed
into oblivion instead it's spirals inward towards
the central star within the black hole. There it
continues to exist even though light from
this matter cannot escape to the outside,
it is enveloped in mystery held
prisoner by a gravitational pull.
Black holes are often portrayed like this it's
what looks like 2D flat space warping into a
funnel but this isn't the whole picture. This
common drawing is not a mistake but a happy
accident born from the need for simplicity. Given
that stars are spherical their collapsed version
is also spherical. The Event Horizon, the point
of no return, is not a circle but instead is a
sphere. If we were inside a black hole we would
find ourselves trapped in ever smaller spheres
as we sunk deeper into its depths. Drawings
like this are missing a dimension, to become
more accurate every circle should actually be
a sphere. The spheres would be overlapping on
top of each other like a Russian doll. Drawings
like this are more of a map of gravity's well.
From the center it would require an enormous
amount of energy to climb out and since black
holes are symmetrical in all directions this
slice is okay to represent the entire sphere.
We can paint a horizon with a a single brush
stroke it signifies the boundary of our sight,
separating water from sky. A ship sailing over
the horizon won't stop existing once it passes
it and the sailors wouldn't notice it's just us
onlookers back on the beach who will think the
boat has disappeared. The same is true for the
horizon of a black hole. If our friend Carlo was
to travel to a large black hole and managed
to cross the Event Horizon he wouldn't even
notice. Super-massive black holes are large
enough that changes in gravity are spread out
and they are less likely to hurt you. It's only
the small black holes you need to worry about,
they could turn you into spaghetti because
gravity's well is very steep. Carlo's watch
continues ticking at its normal rate but to
us watching from the outside he would slow to
a stop. Past the Horizon Carlo would disappear
from our sight because the light from him could
no longer reach us but Carlo himself would be
happily bobbing along deeper into the black
hole. Many textbooks condemn whoever enters
a black hole but don't worry Carlo could come
out again he just needs to find another way
out and that happens to be via a white hole.
Einstein gifted us the idea that gravity is the
distortion of spacetime where the spacetime grid
represents events each with a position and
a time. So the gravity well of a black hole
can be represented by a funnel of space time
and as the black hole ages the shape changes,
lengthening and growing narrower with the
passage of time. We only know this thanks to
Einstein's equations which illuminate that which
would otherwise be invisible to us. Einstein's
equations do have a limitation though they can't
be used to describe extreme conditions and for
the black hole things do get extreme. As the
diameter of the funnel narrows the cylinder
becomes more curved like a roll that is rolled
tighter and tighter. This distortion of spacetime
is so severe that Einstein's equations no longer
work, luckily though quantum physics can save us.
When it rains and water falls from the
sky it doesn't fall in one continuous
flow instead it falls in millions of
tiny individual droplets. Each happy
little droplet could be called a quanta
of rain where the word quanta means the
smallest unit that makes up a whole. Now
let your imagination wander to light,
it too can be thought of as a shower of
light drops instead of a continuous flow.
These individual bundles or quanta of light are
what we are describing with quantum physics. We
could also think about splitting space itself up
into quanta. If each little piece of SpaceTime is
like a grain of sand then together they make
up the beach of our universe. The inside of
a black hole cannot be squashed any further than
the size of the individual grains of spacetime,
this is where Einstein's equations stop working,
here space is distorted on the quantum level.
If I drop a ball it falls to the ground then
bounces back up. In a black hole spacetime is
falling upon itself so shouldn't it also be able
to bounce back? When a ball bounces it's as if a
film of its fall were being played in reverse.
If we played a film of a black hole in reverse,
what would we see we would see? The
star and spacetime bouncing back,
we would see a white hole. A white hole is a
black hole played backwards in time. Quantum
physics links the two spacetimes because the
transition occurs when space is squashed beyond
its granular limit. In quantum physics things
don't always have a position they can be nowhere,
living in a haze of probabilities. This fact
allows particles to leap or tunnel through space
and grains of space themselves might also be able
to leap, flipping a black hole to a white one.
In a black hole you can enter but not leave and
in a white hole you can leave but not enter.
Anything that enters a black hole can dance with
the limits of space and time before passing into
a white hole and coming out again. An unsettling
thought is that from the outside we can't easily
distinguish a black hole from a white one.
One may expect that with the hands of time
running backwards that the pull of gravity would
turn into a push but that's not the case. In a
film of the solar system being run backwards
the sun still pulls the planets in a cosmic
embrace. Nothing can cross the Horizon and enter
a white hole but watching from afar we never see
anything cross the horizon and enter a black
hole either. To us Carlo's time would appear
to slow as he approached the Horizon of a black
hole crawling to a stop. It would seem to take
an Infinity for him to cross the horizon and
even if we stayed up late we'd never catch it.
With black and white holes appearing the same
from afar we are reminded of the importance
of looking beyond what can be immediately seen.
We might not be correct about white holes. They
might not exist at all or have properties
that we weren't anticipating. One idea is
that a black hole and a white hole could be
linked forming a kind of wormhole between two
universes or two regions of space bridging
across the fourth dimension. The scientists
who have given us these ideas have done their
best to paint accurate pictures but paintings
require a bit of creativity and in that way
scientists are artists. I think there's an
artist hidden at the heart of every one of us.
You too can paint inspiring pictures so how would
you imagine the inside of a white hole? Having
doubts is okay, that's the thrill of science,
always wondering if what you've done is correct
with uncertainty growing into new bigger ideas.
Carlo Rovelli is a physicist who has spent much
of his life studying the quantum aspects of space
and time and his book White Holes is not just
about explaining the scientific ideas but is also
about the mind of a scientist at work. He mentions
other ideas of white holes including that the Big
Bang which created this universe of ours could
have been a white hole that was formed from a
collapsing universe bouncing back. Rovelli writes
in a very poetic way that can communicate the
ideas of physics to someone who doesn't know much
about it but also can offer new perspectives for
someone who knows a lot already. There's a link to
order a copy of his book down in the description.
Thank you to Riverhead books for
sponsoring this video and thank
you for watching. I hope that you
have an absolutely mathematical day!
Thanks for watching this video and
thanks to my Patreon supporters for
making it possible a special shout out
to today's Patron cat of the day Cassini.